how's it going bros it's me and I were
you money made come on I look like a
penis who wears this on ironically how
much should I spend on this now I'm
ready to rob a bank
the Gucci bank what look why everybody
you know if past PewDiePie could see
himself now he would be so proud
oh my god is worse without it ok enough
about the mask alright my Matt my face
is warm I love it I absolutely love it
thank you Gucci for sponsoring this
video well let's begin why leave your I
[Music]
made him laugh we're making progress
stop this meme needs to stop it ends
here ok cuz I'm not giving you any
reaction you had your fun now leave this
Alex Vause guy celebrated article 13
let's make a meme out of him it's cool
that I get to I get to see the same
memes that I posted myself but by you
guys good job good job
I feel like now that memes are banned
yeah
that's the real reason I gotta wear this
hood no one can know my identity alright
memes are illegal now the man behind
Eve's copyright law is surprised by
what's in the proposal what they're
French I didn't know that this was in
the proposed so so far so of course I
have to deal with it now yeah you deal
with it Alex look at me Alex
you
[Music]
so engagement you have been living under
a rock
EU ban means and this guy apparently
didn't even know what he voted for can
someone remind him that's right
when I hit 500,000 subscribers I will
lick my I never said this I never said
this but I will however do it anyway
because I always keep a promise can you
physically do it listen I'm not gonna do
it I just want to know if you can refine
if peopIe from the past tune in now he
would be very proud he's judging me shut
up
Hey look it's another meme I've already
showed in a video because I saw it
elsewhere alright
honestly like I said I wanted to do the
green screen so that you guys could just
post ironic reaction memes but it seems
like everyone just wanted a green screen
thing so I'll link a new green screen
competition where I'll do some actual
moves and say some things instead of me
awkwardly just going which apparently
means something else final attempt to
get pewds and Mertz to see my drawing
that's amazing maybe draw me next time
what are you doing well this is actually
epic fortnight has now been sighted in
more than 200 divorce proceedings this
is epic can we hit 500 divorce
proceedings this thing is itchy as hell
oh great it's another meme from duck
well done duckling well done good joke
good mean I'm honestly surprised is this
200 if like an emergency I played
fortnight the weddings would just
instantly be canceled
okay here we go using the drink format
using the new improved poppy Harlow
version this is what I'm talking about
render me daddy ill I love the bottle
one somewhat let me show you guys hey
I just love this reaction so much it
took me so many attempts to get it right
come on
it's the god-like reaction
you're not gonna get anything more than
that no one used state this is a
complete failure
this however that's epic did Brad just
because of the Hurricanes hmm no museums
in the future when are you guys gonna
let it go I'm trying to rebuild my
reputation okay so stop please stop
referencing like it or hate it that's
history right there
welcome to 2018 a picture of a young man
holding hands with this apparent
girlfriend while looking and whistling
at another woman walking by the
seemingly irritated girlfriend is
labeled Internet censorship that's the
Internet community and the other woman
and provide solution hey you know what
this is not bad when the band memes I
can still enjoy memes we figured it out
boys you know what for a bunch of
nine-year-olds you guys aren't that dumb
slightly more entertaining than the
actual me we're gonna die in a gulag but
man it'll be worth it it's funny cuz
it's true
absolute man lads absolute insane lads
wait that's a thing my face is so hot I
hate this okay
wait yeah well vanish dog that's
standish dog Hey look at that as mean
still kickin it good job good job
everyone today I saw an Indian guy
betraying t-series I think we're winning
boys yes this is truly the only way we
can beat t-series by recruiting Indians
if you're an Indian police smash
subscribe we'll take any one dick ahead
que se dice yacht lane he said the seat
ollie
it's not that hard is it the badge means
means an honorable nine year old
commander he leads the Indians
let's ask pues to learn Russian so he
could understand Russian memes and
conquer T series with Russian audience
all I understand Russian memes it's all
suit gabion dish and cyka be a dick okay
I saw there is to it okay is that pee
I in spider-man's costume why just
because I didn't nail the handshake
there's nothing wrong this is
discrimination
this is cyberbullying and I will not
stand for this Jesus look even
spider-man can fail this is so relatable
superhumans are humans too super PETA
super whatever I'm so glad I did the
whole gift competition because everyone
is using it what a great idea
hey Felix we want you to give us more
challenges ok here you go
Oh f-you Felix 10 or space everybody now
this is a speed comedy right there I'm
laughing ok that's epic you know what I
take it back that's actually awesome
nice one Pano's stam Oh amazing if this
video gets 400,000 likes I will play
like I already played it stop crying you
nine-year-old babies hey hey look it's
the same mean goddamn my face is 18 wait
a second oh my god oh my god oh yeah ok
I don't know what I just did we have
officially peaked wait I got my ass
cutie pie to make a 5 minute video which
shall be slowed down to X so it will
have 10 minutes and we as viewers will
set playback speed to 2 X equals
monetize this is genius we I will do
this way I gotta send this to bride
marijuana alcohol drugs telling your
daughter about your dominatrix job
wearing Gucci alright so if I hit 66
million subscribers I will play a lego
star this is a lie why do you guys want
me to play Lego so badly Scooby Doo
Scrappy Doo
get out the dare proof of whom face
being beautifies original face nanny
alright that was this week's LA
YouTube's favorite show everybody smash
like if you enjoyed watching and
subscribe so we can beat the Indians I
mean T series of course and let me know
what I should wear in the next episode
and I'll see you guys next time
brofist
[Music]
awesome
great